the universe speaks to us always first
in whispers the alternative is a life
filled with regret there is a source of
power in you that transcends the person
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up elimination it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee on
sip on today's message listen to the
universe over you Oprah Winfrey also if
you want to know what Oprah and other
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
free morning video to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below I have paid
attention to my life because I
understand that my life just like your
life is always speaking to you there
real work is to figure out where your
power base is the universe speaks to us
always first in whispers
and a whisper usually in your life feels
like hmm that's odd or hmm that doesn't
make any sense or hmm is that right it
just really feels like that it's that
it's that kind of subtle and if you
don't pay attention to the whisper it
gets louder and louder and louder and I
say it's like getting thumped upside the
head you don't pay attention to that
it's like getting a brick upside your
head you don't pay attention to that the
brick wall falls down that is the
pattern that I see in my life in so many
other people's lives and so I ask people
what are the whispers what's whispering
to you now and can you catch it in the
whisper you already know what you want
to do you're letting the opinions of
other people get in the way of you
taking action people are not afraid of
feeling they're afraid of failing in
front of other people
you will sing all day in the shower but
you won't get on the street corner in
shame because you're embarrassed of the
judgement and what you need to do is
inoculate yourself against the judgment
and learn to take action on your ideas
because the alternative is a life filled
with regret you have to decide at what
point are you gonna take ownership for
where you are in life like at what point
do you decide my goals my ideas my
dreams my ambitions are important enough
to me that I'm willing to risk failure
I'm willing to risk embarrassment I'm
willing to risk having to go tell my
friends that it didn't work out because
this is my path because otherwise I
never get to do the thing that I want to
do at what point are you gonna decide to
step up and say I need to do this for me
I need to know it may not work out I may
be embarrassed but I need to know I
don't want the rest of my life to sit
around wondering what if what if what if
so it's really important to listen to
the universe but then you have to take
action you got to do something about it
and I got a three step process that I
think is gonna help you its audit act
adjust audit act adjust so let's start
with audit audit is listening audit is
paying attention maybe you hear the
whispers maybe you get hit with the
pick in the face you are listening
you're paying attention whatever the
thing is that helps you find that spot I
think too many of us are so
overstimulated constantly right we're
like reaching for our phone any minute
of downtime we're on our phone playing
heyday or whatever whatever the game is
checking in a social media network like
when is your time to audit to reflect to
think to connect building that in
learning to when you're walking down the
street just walk down the street and
think and reflect like building maybe an
evening walk to just digest what
happened that day whether it's on the
weekend you're gonna go hang out of the
Starbucks or go out in nature or make
meditation part of your practice if you
are constantly on the go and on the go
doesn't mean working like people often
will pull out their phones and play a
game as a way to de-stress and unwind
and relax but it means your brain is
always on you need to have time built
into your day consistently where you can
just reflect where you can audit where
the ideas can flow to you and you can
start building a list of the things that
you want to try and test for the life
that you want to build for yourself
audit next is act you got to act you got
to do something I have the 595 rule you
spend five percent of your time thinking
strategizing planning and then 95
percent of your time doing most people
flip it most people spend all their time
just thinking and planning and
strategizing and writing the business
plan and then another business plan and
adjusting and tweaking the business plan
you will not figure things out sitting
on the couch you have to do you have to
get out you need to act the best thing
that you can do is take the list of
ideas that you have
take everything you came up with in the
audit section and do something on it
find the smallest possible way to get
started and test it if one of your ideas
is build a YouTube channel make youtube
videos don't make it complicated like
today take out your phone
record yourself making a video and post
it expect it to be absolute garbage it's
okay did you enjoy the process do you
want to go back to it you can't think
your way through these things you can
think of the idea but it's the feeling
that you get by acting that dick takes
the momentum and ultimately
whether you would get results or not so
the 595 rule find the smallest possible
way to get started on the ideas that you
have the smallest possible way to do
something today and then spend 95% of
your time actually doing and only 5% of
your time strategizing planning and
thinking about it and then the third day
is adjust this is where people get it
wrong life success is not about hitting
it right the first time you will not hit
it right the first time it's about
trying it's about acting and then
adjusting you make a plan you do the
plan you act on the plane and then you
adjust the plan you start with is never
never never never gonna be the plan you
end up with that's where the success
will come is the ability to adjust your
initial idea and then change it and make
it better Lamborghini started selling
tractors Wrigley started selling baking
soda and soap and move to gum BMW
started selling airplanes it's why their
logo is a propeller and moved the cars
you adjust you have a plan you have a
great idea every idea that I come up
with I think is genius I launched it I
find some small way to act on it and
then adjust adjust adjust adjust adjust
adjust so many people are so concerned
about building the perfect plan the
perfect product the perfect service but
really it's just a front it's just an
insecurity because you're afraid and the
cure the way through is to audit to act
and adjust now I've got a really special
bonus clip that I think you're going to
enjoy but before that it's time for the
question of the day I want to know what
is a universe telling you to do and how
will you act on it today let me know put
it down in the comments below
there is a source of power in you that
transcends the person and is not egoic
power over somebody and it's one with
the power that is the power of life in
the universe where all life arises and
people sometimes have a problem with
self-confidence or valuing yourself and
sometimes you try to convince yourself
by changing your thinking that you are
actually good enough that you should be
self-confident but there is a better way
to find the source of self-confidence on
the egoic level self-confidence is there
because you see you can tell yourself
I'm actually more intelligent in most of
these people or I'm better-looking than
most I have to remind myself that I'm
better-looking in most and then okay I
feel a bit more confident now
or you say I've actually have more money
than these people so I should have more
self-confidence whatever it is some way
of convincing yourself and then you
compare yourself with others and then
you focus in on those areas where you
feel superior to others and try not to
think about other areas where inevitably
you are inferior to others because you
cannot be superior in all areas it's a
complicated game when you start start
comparing yourself to other people and
if you want to bolster yourself
confidence and you only have to focus on
where you feel I'm actually better than
most but that doesn't really work that
well so there is a better way of self
confidence that has nothing to do with
comparing yourself with others or with
feeling you're better than or not as
good as and that is direct access to
inner power you don't need any
comparison you can have it right now at
this very moment if you're not stuck in
your thinking mind but take your
attention a little bit beyond the
thinking mind and then realize that you
are the presence behind the thinking
mind without which there could be no
thinking you're the aware presence
behind it all that is deeper you've gone
deeper than the thinking mind and that
aware presence is where power resides
and it's not yours because it connects
you with universal power therefore you
don't need to compare yourself to
anybody anymore or feel as the ego
always does that you are either superior
or inferior
to somebody else it's a not a
comfortable way to live where you have
to classify yourself and you made people
and so you've if the fear is over I
might be inferior or behind that fear is
a desire to be superior if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you up or that would
be like a little beacon if you liked
this video and want more Oprah check out
the top 10 vol 3 we did on her I think
you're gonna really enjoy the link is
right there next to me continue to
believe and I'll see you there it was
very difficult for me to figure out
where my boundaries were because I'd
grown up poor and didn't have anything